only one thing about Todd Phillips
standalone Joker movie is certain this
isn't gonna be any old superhero film
here are all the reasons why it's time
to get hyped about this brand new take
on the Dark Knight's greatest nemesis
first things first this isn't a Batman
movie sure Bruce Wayne has been cast but
in this movie he's a child with no idea
what's still to come he's not the focus
the protagonist or even a major player
this is a story about the Joker and the
world that made him but just as the
greatest Batman stories are often about
the kind of evil he faces down so too
might this story be about the good that
the Joker fights that means this film
isn't just capable of being a great
Joker story but also a great story about
Gotham itself - and that's a perspective
even fans of the comics rarely get to
see legendary actors aren't new to
superhero films and even the Joker
himself has been portrayed by some
world-class performers watch special
face but more often than not caped
adventures simply act as a springboard
for actors to reach greater heights
Chris Evans was Captain America before
he directed his own film Mary Jane
Watson was an important step towards
Kirsten Dunst becoming a legendary
actress and Wolverine gave Hugh Jackman
the chance to eventually make some of
his dream musical projects often capes
and cowls are what you start with not
necessarily what you aim for so it's not
every day that an actor like Joaquin
Phoenix steps up to play a Denison of
Gotham City
Phoenix is when Grammy Awards been
nominated three times for Oscars and
garnered acclaim across multiple genres
and mediums from the master to gladiator
to a soundtrack work for walk the line
he's time and time again proved his
worth as an artist with vision passion
and drive Phoenix isn't just a star you
can count on to play a role well he's
someone you can count on to make it his
own to say that DC's Cinematic Universe
has encountered a few rough patches here
and there would be an understatement to
say the least
even the franchise's flagship movies
such as Batman vs Superman and Suicide
Squad tend to attract more criticism
than praise it's not all bad of course
Shazam has practically reinvigorated the
franchise and both Wonder Woman and
Aquaman played well with audiences but
it doesn't exactly make things easier
normally this wouldn't be good news for
a DC movie like Joker but one benefit of
the DC films trouble
is that they forced Warner Brothers to
allow their movies to try new things and
so it goes for Joker which is being
promoted as an independent creation
inspired by the DC universes mythology
but without having to obey it entirely
this means the film will be able to take
creative risks and make decisions
without having to make sure it all fits
in with the Justice League timeline DC's
Elseworlds publishing imprint was a
similarly mined adventure that led to
the publication of some of the best
superhero comics ever made now fans will
finally get to see how that experiment
translates to the silver screen director
Todd Phillips is the guy behind the
hangover trilogy first and foremost but
he's also worked on many films before
and since from Borat to wor dogs most
notably he's renowned for his work with
comedy this works well for Joker since
Phillips will be a comedian telling a
comedian story a director well-versed in
the kind of gritty thriller Joker aims
to be would be one thing but what
cinematic alchemy might happen when the
guy behind the camera really understands
what it's like to be inside Arthur flex
head the Joker is at his best both scary
and funny and who better to make that
terrifying contrast to reality than a
proven jokester Gotham City has been
subject to countless differing
interpretations over the years there's
Tim Burton's ultra stylized neo-gothic
Fantasia where secretaries have neon
signs in their bedrooms and modern
department stores still advertised with
1950s style signage there's also Nolan's
mega city which is practically
indistinguishable from modern-day
Manhattan Joker however seems to be
taking a different tack entirely with
the trailer seemingly implying that it
takes place at a Gotham based on 1970s
New York City it depicts seedy peep
shows clearly riffing on the Times
Square of that era an Arkham that Nurse
Ratched could have proud and comedy
clubs full of that classic 70s mustard
gold and brown pallets it's a period
rarely explored by modern comic-book
movies and one that will doubtless help
Joker stand out from the crowd some of
the most inventive films of all time
found their success by taking influence
from unexpected places
for example Mad Max fury road will
likely go down as one of the greatest
action films of all time and one of the
only to hire Eve Ensler of The Vagina
Monologues as a consultant equally
guardians of the galaxy brought new zest
to marble by plumbing the depths of
1970s music
bro me versus you it's on and now we
have Joker which todd phillips says
we'll call martin scorsese it's number
one influence particularly Raging Bull
the King of Comedy and taxi driver
Scorsese was actually set to co-produced
the film until he dropped out in 2018
but his primacy is a figure in the
production of the film doesn't seem to
have changed in a comic book film
already full of innovations and
subversions from the norm the influence
of a great like Scorsese is surely the
most exciting check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you